LILLI THOMPSON: Hello.
I'm Lilli Thompson, and this
is Console to Chrome, HTML5
and JavaScript for
game developers.
So first of all, just a little
bit of background on me.
So I am an ex-console game
programmer that joined Google
as a software engineer.
And I did that for a couple of
years, nothing to do with
graphics or game, just generic
software engineering.
And then, I found that
I really missed game
development.
So I then joined the
Chrome team as a
game developer advocate.
And what that means is that what
I do now is that I work
with game developers who are
working with technologies that
are a priority for Chrome.
And the big two for me
are HTML5 and WebGL.
So that's what I do a lot of,
and that's why I'm here today.
So first of all, an overview
of this talk.
The thing you really need to
know is that this is a
201-level talk.
I'm not going to give
you the HTML5 pitch.
And I'm not going to give you an
intro to game development.
I'm going to assume that you're
a game developer type
person that already knows that
they want to use HTML5.
Maybe you've done a WebGL
tutorial and even rendered
your first couple
of triangles.
But now, there's a huge
knowledge gap between making a
prototype and actually
making a scalable
large-scale game engine.
And so that's really what
I want to address today.
And there are a couple of topics
that go into that.
The first, I'll just have to
go really briefly over the
HTML5 APIs.
I'm not going to spend
a lot of time on it.
But I want to make sure that
we're all on the same page.
Then the real meat of the
issue for a lot of game
developers is JavaScript.
Just writing code at that
scale in JavaScript is
something that a lot of console
programmers struggle with.
And so I'm going to spend a lot
of time there in talking
about how to do that.
And then finally, when you write
an HTML5 game, you're
actually writing a game that
renders inside a much more
complicated system of Chrome's
rendering system.
And so there's all sorts of
things to know there.
And if you really understand how
Chrome is set up, you can
optimize your game and
make it run better.
So those are the topics I'm
going to cover today.
So there are two major
ways that people
think about HTML5 games.
The first is as a means
to get ubiquity.
There's a whole class of people
who look at HTML5 as a
way to write one code base and
run it in multiple places.
So the dream is that every
phone, every tablet, every PC,
every device has a browser.
And if you can squish your
game into a browser, into
HTML5, then that's great
for your maintenance.
You have one code base, and
it's running everywhere.
That's awesome.
But that particular use of HTML5
comes with a certain set
of constraints.
So naturally, if you're really
targeting ubiquity, if that's
your point, then you have to peg
the specification for your
game to the lowest common
denominator, both in terms of
what APIs you can use, because
you need APIs that are very
broadly supported, and also in
terms of what you can demand
out of the hardware because you
have to assume that you
want to run just as well on a
phone as you do on a desktop.
So anyway, very nice use of
HTML5, but then there's this
other way people think about
it, which is as a way to do
something awesome with
the browser.
So there's a different set of
people who see the browser as
a distribution platform for
their console-style games and
are really excited by all the
great new potential that HTML5
had added to the browser.
And they really want to take
advantage of that.
And there's a huge potential
there, making sharable,
linkable, seamless
experiences.
You can get so many
users that way.
And it's so exciting.
But as you can imagine, these
people who are really
interested in being on the
leading edge, their goals are
very different than the people
who are trying to
do HTML5 for ubiquity.
Because by virtue of being on
the bleeding edge, these
things aren't going to be
supported everywhere.
If you're making a game that's
a PC-style game that's really
demanding, it's not going to run
on 10-year-old hardware.
And that's OK for
this use case.
So whenever you talk to people
about their opinions about
HTML5 and what it's good for
and what it isn't good for,
you should make sure you
understand which of these
cases they're coming
at it from.
And to be very clear here,
what I want to talk about
today is the leading
edge of HTML5.
I want to talk about credible
console-style experiences
rendered in the browser.
So to begin talking about that,
we need to talk about
HTML5 APIs, at least briefly.
So the first one you're going
to need is WebGL.
So WebGL is the way you do 3D
rendering in a browser.
It's a lot like OpenGL.
So if you're already an OpenGL
programmer, it's going to be
pretty familiar to you,
except for it's
actually OpenGL ES 2.0.
It's the embedded systems
version of OpenGL.
And what that means is that when
they made the embedded
systems versions of the
specifications, they took out
everything that was deemed to be
redundant in order to make
it small and compact to
fit on mobile devices.
But that means that a lot of
stuff is sort of removed.
And the first thing you're going
to notice there is that
fixed function lighting
is gone.
So all your rendering in WebGL
is going to be done through
programmable shaders.
You're going to have to get
used to that if you're not
used to that already.
And besides that, there are a
bunch of other little things
which, when I talk to game
developers about them, they're
usually described as annoyances,
just random stuff
that just is missing for
whatever reason in the
specification.
So for instance, depth buffer
access, texture compression is
only available in a limited
form, instancing is missing,
and so on, and so forth.
So there are little
stumbling blocks.
None of them are
deal breakers.
You can still make a
high-quality, graphically
impressive 3D game.
But you're going to
have to know that
these issues are there.
And then, there's a different
class of things, which is a
set of operations in OpenGL
ES that have a different
performance profile than you
might expect in Chrome.
So, for instance, anything that
starts with a "read,"
anything that's starts with a
"get" and "glFinish," that
kind of operation, they're
all going to be extra
expensive in Chrome.
They were always somewhat
expensive.
Now they're going to be
really expensive.
And when we get into talking
about how Chrome actually
renders things, I'll be able
to explain why that is.
But besides those performance
notes, the rest of the
performance of WebGL is
actually pretty great.
It's actually tremendously
impressive.
It's really calling straight
through the hardware, so the
performance of WebGL is very,
very similar to the
performance of OpenGL.
And you can get a
lot out of it.
And the other thing to note is
that the specification is
evolving very, very quickly.
If you look at where WebGL was
a year ago versus where it is
today, you're going to see
a lot of improvements.
So especially, when you think
about all these little things
that are either annoying, or
missing, or whatever, make
sure you check back in with your
assumptions every three
to six months because fixes very
well might have come into
the specification.
Or better still, go to the WebGL
mailing list and start
talking about what it is you
need and want, because they're
very responsive, and a lot of
changes are getting made.
So you can render polygons.
Next thing you need to do on
your way to a prototype is to
be able to play some audio.
HTML5 audio is a notorious
sticking point.
Everyone in the HTML5 games
community has heard everybody
else complain about how
painful audio is.
And that's pretty true,
quite honestly.
It's pretty safe to say that
audio in HTML5 is the most
important, least standardized
thing.
And so there actually is no
specification that's really
suitable for this kind of game
that's going to work
everywhere.
So you're stuck falling back and
doing different things for
different browsers.
I wish it wasn't the case, but
that's sort of the world we
live in today.
Of all the specifications out
there, the one that I
personally think is the best and
most suitable for games is
the web audio API, which is
only in Chrome right now.
And it offers just a lot
of features, sort of a
graph-based audio processing
system, all kinds of
out-of-the-box nodes and filters
you can just use.
It's hardware accelerated.
It's very accurate in
its timing, and
so on, and so forth.
So it will help you out.
And then, there's so much more
that I just don't have time to
get to today.
There's all kinds of new APIs
being added to the HTML5
standards all the time.
Instead of trying to go over
them here, because I just
don't have time, I'm going to
add a resources slide at the
end where you can go and read
about any one of these
particular things.
There are also lots of
presentations that sort of
catalog APIs for games.
But suffice to say for the
moment, there are a lot of
things that you should
look into.
If these things don't look
familiar to you yet, then you
should go look them up and see
if they're useful to you.
And that's pretty
much for HTML5.
Pretty much two things you need,
You need to be able to
render triangles.
You need to be able
to play sound.
From there, you can
make a prototype.
Once you've got a prototype, now
comes the hard part where
you take prototype
to game engine.
And that transition is all about
writing high-performance
JavaScript.
So that's what we're going
to talk about now.
And before I get too deep into
it, a great big caveat that
what I'm talking about
is JavaScript
performance for Chrome.
Every browser has its own
JavaScript engine, or there
are many different JavaScript
implementations.
And they're all going to have
different performance quirks.
Certain operations are going to
be slow over here, and fast
over there, and all that.
So this presentation, I'm
going to try to give you
general information.
But this information has been
written in the context of V8
and sort of confirmed with
the V8 team for accuracy.
And I'm not trying to
or qualified to
speak for other browsers.
So let's talk JavaScript.
JavaScript is a high-level
scripting language.
And it's extremely permissive
in what it allows you to do,
extremely squishy
in its syntax.
It's typeless.
It's kind of interpreted.
It's just-in-time compiled.
There's no explicit syntax
for memory management.
And it's all running on a single
thread with some HTML5
exceptions called web workers
which you should go look up if
you don't know what
they are already.
So the nice thing about
JavaScript is that it's great
to have an application running
in JavaScript in front of your
end users because it is great
at not falling down.
JavaScript is great at eating
bad input and staying up.
Nothing makes it crash.
It's super effective at being
robust. The sort of dark side
of that, though, is that because
JavaScript doesn't
have a lot of structure of its
own and because it is really,
really permissive in what it
allows you to do, and it never
sort of spits errors at you,
that while you're developing,
you're sort of stuck
in this Wild West
kind of lawless world.
And it's really hard to work in
that kind of unstructured
environment.
So from a developer standpoint,
what I usually
think is that you want a really
permissive system for
deployment, because you don't
want to put something in front
of end users that will crash.
And you want a really strict
system for development so that
JavaScript doesn't allow you
to do anything silly.
And JavaScript being way over
on the permissive end of the
spectrum, development of
large-scale systems in it can
be difficult.
So what people do, because
JavaScript doesn't bring a lot
of structure of its own, is that
they impose artificial
structure on JavaScript.
So either they have their team
follow very strict coding
standards, or there are patterns
that allow you to
privatize data.
Even though JavaScript doesn't
have an actual way to
privatize data, you can
sort of fake it
with certain patterns.
There are post-processing tools
that will warn you or
add static types and tell
you when you're
doing something silly.
So there's all that kind of
stuff that you should be aware
if you're making a large-scale
JavaScript application.
And then you should also just
be aware that JavaScript is
not going to spit a lot
of errors at you.
So when there are problems in a
certain part of your system,
it might be hard to figure out
what exactly has gone wrong,
because JavaScript always thinks
that everything is OK.
So it's hard to trace
back error chains.
And in an environment like that,
you want to code extra
defensively.
The idea is that you want to
design your system in a
modular way, which is
always a good idea.
And then, hopefully, you can
design it such that if one of
your modules starts behaving
strangely, starts going wonky,
and you can't figure out why,
you can just kill it, and
restart a fresh one, and
reconnect it to your system
while the whole thing
is running.
And if you can design in that
way, you'll save yourself a
lot of pain dealing in the
system that's sort of squishy.
So if you're still one of those
people who thinks to
themselves, well, JavaScript,
that's a scripting language.
You could never actually write
a high-performance credible
game in JavaScript.
You are dealing with seriously
dated information.
JavaScript engines are really
fast these days.
They are absolutely capable of
doing the kind of processing
required for this
kind of game.
The problem is that it's just
really easy to write bad code
in JavaScript.
And there are a ton of examples
of bad code in
JavaScript that people tend
to follow as patterns.
So not only is JavaScript
performance squirrely in that
it's hard to tell what exactly
is going wrong, or small
changes in your JavaScript can
have really, really big
performance implications, and
that information isn't really
surfaced all that well to you as
a developer, but on top of
all that, the VM itself, the
actual virtual machine that's
executing your JavaScript, V8
in Chrome's case, is under
development too.
So something that was slow
yesterday might be fast today.
And so you have to keep all of
this in your mind as you're
trying to write high-performance
JavaScript.
So the best way I know how to
give advice on how to write
high-performance JavaScript is
to explain to you the pieces,
the general components
of how V8 is
actually executing things.
And then, you can develop an
intuition for what might be
fast and what might be slow,
and go from there.
So again, I'm talking about
components of V8 here.
In general, these are components
you find in a lot
of JavaScript engines.
But this, in particular,
is referencing V8's
implementation.
So the components are you have
a just-in-time compiler.
That compiler compiles two sum
representations, so you have
an object model under
the hood.
You have an optimizing
compiler that
compiles after that.
And then, at the end of the
day, you have a garbage
collector that's running around
cleaning up after you.
So I'll talk about each
of these components.
First of all, the just-in-time
compiler.
So the just-in-time compiler,
what it does is
very easy to explain.
It looks at the JavaScript
you wrote.
And it takes snippets of your
JavaScript, and it turns them
into native code.
And that translation, the
directive of the just-in-time
compiler, is to do that as
quickly as possible.
It doesn't try to be overly
clever or to specialize or
optimize at that point.
It's trying to make the
interpretation of JavaScript
files fast. So it just
does that translation
as fast as it can.
And it does a great job of it.
So when we talk about the
just-in-time compiler, we're
talking about generating
native code.
So now we need to talk
about what kind of
native code gets generated.
We need to talk about
data types.
So the first data type of
interest is numbers, numeric
types, of course,
very important.
So V8 has two major internal
representations of numbers.
There are small ints values
and heap numbers, and they
have different performance
profiles.
So small ints are the case you
want to be in if you can.
They are immediate values as
opposed to heap numbers, which
are allocated somewhere
else on the heap.
Small ints are something you're
just holding on to.
And that means they're really
fast to interact with.
The size of a heap number is
an interesting question.
On 32-bit machines, heap numbers
are ints that are 31
bits or less.
On 64-bit machines, small ints
are 32 bits or less.
So there's some sort
of intricacy there.
In general, you probably want to
target both 32-bit machines
and 64-bit machines.
So you probably want
to aim for 31-bit
integers if you can.
Now, don't go crazy with this,
because other kinds of numbers
can be optimized later too.
But if you have a system, like
your OPT tree system or your
particle system that lends
itself to being cast in terms
of integer math, it might be a
major performance improvement
for you if you can get into
these SMI values.
So that's SMIs.
Then we have heap numbers.
So heap numbers are anything
that won't fit into an SMI and
is not a local variable.
So exactly like you'd expect,
these numbers can't be
allocated in an immediate
mode.
So they need to be wrapped up
and allocated on the heap,
which means that now they're
going to be slightly slower to
deal with because you're
referencing a number that's
somewhere else.
Now, before you go crazy, again,
I want to make sure
that I don't accidentally tell
you to overspecialize.
Doubles are sometimes
optimized.
V8 knows that math is
really important.
It's something people
want to do a lot of.
So we'll try to optimize
your doubles.
It'll try to allocate them
in immediate mode.
in registers if it can.
But it might not be able to, so
there's no guarantee there.
So again, don't go crazy trying
to make all small ints.
But if you can, if it lends
itself to your system, it
could work for you.
So that's numbers.
Next, we need to talk
about arrays.
So the first type of array to
talk about in JavaScript is
the TypedArray.
So TypedArrays are going to make
a lot of sense to you if
you're coming from
a C background.
They are contiguous blocks of
memory that are specified for
a particular data type.
So you have Uint32Array,
Float64Array, Uint8Array, and
so on, and so forth, which
actually, if you're familiar
with JavaScript, is
sort of unusual.
Because most things in
JavaScript have no type.
So this idea that we're
specifying a very specific
size for our numbers is actually
like pretty unique.
And that's because the
TypedArray specification grew
up alongside the WebGL
specification.
And you can imagine how you need
that level of specificity
if you're doing graphics
programming.
So that's sort of where
the TypedArray
specification came from.
But it's been adopted
into other things
now that it's there.
So again, they're memory
efficient.
You don't have to box them.
They behave as you'd expect.
They're a very nice
option for arrays.
But if you can't use TypedArrays
for whatever
reason, you need to use
JavaScript Arrays.
So JavaScript Array object--
Array with a capital A--
has an API which is going to
look a little weird to you if
you are used to C-style
arrays.
It's going to have operations
that are different.
It's going to have like
push and pop.
It's going to allow you to
index out of bounds.
It's going to have just sort
of odd behavior to me as
somebody coming from C.
So as you can imagine, because
the API allows all these non-C
array-like things, the backing
storage in V8 is not always
something that looks
like an array.
There are actually two different
types of backing
storage for arrays.
There are sparse arrays and
dense arrays, which map to
either something that looks
like a C-style array, like
you'd expect, or a hash table.
And if your array is backed by a
V8 hash table, that's called
being in dictionary
mode, and it's
considerably less efficient.
It's a case that you
want to avoid.
There are many factors in V8
that causes you to be kicked
into dictionary mode or not.
So it's kind of complicated
to define them all.
But one of them, for instance,
is space efficiency.
So if the codes you wrote will
be three times more efficient,
use three times less space if it
was backed by a hash table
than an array, then it'll be a
hash table on the back end.
So there are criteria
like that.
Let me give you an example.
So this is something that
JavaScript allows you to do.
JavaScript allows you to create
a new uninitialized
array and then just suddenly
index into
it at whatever index.
This, of course, doesn't make
any sense in C. It's not
something you'd actually do.
And in V8, it will immediately
trigger dictionary mode.
So this, you will now have a
nice, slow array to work with,
not something you want.
This is an example of a better
way to do things.
So real simple change.
All you have to do is
declare how much
storage you want up front.
Now you have declared to V8
that you actually want an
array of a certain size.
V8 will back your array by a
contiguous array of that size,
and you can go from there.
Very sensible, kind of
no-brainerish, but again,
JavaScript allows you to do it
in a way that ends up being
very inefficient, so it's
important to know.
So that is the numeric
representation and the
immediate representation
of objects.
Now, we're going to talk about
representing JavaScript
objects in V8.
So objects in JavaScript
are these very
poorly defined things.
They are associative arrays.
They're just bundles of key
value pairs of properties.
So you have string value for
key, property value.
And all property values are
these undefined whatevers,
because JavaScript doesn't
have a notion of type.
Objects have prototype chains.
You can add and remove
properties anywhere at the
prototype chain and on the
object itself at any point.
JavaScript doesn't enforce
any specificity or
structure in your code.
So if you wanted to, you could
make every single object in
your whole program absolutely
a unique set of properties.
Nothing in JavaScript will
enforce structure or
self-similarity.
But just because JavaScript
allows you to do that, you
really, really shouldn't.
That's actually a terrible thing
to do for performance.
And I'll explain why
in a minute.
So in V8, the V8 team looked
at trying to write a
large-scale application in
JavaScript and thought, hey,
you know what's important in
large-scale systems is
object-orientedness.
And if you have
object-orientedness in your
system, then now, property
access is one of the key
things that you need to make
fast. So V8 designed its
structure to make property
access on objects as efficient
as it could be.
So the internal representation
of an object
in V8 is three words.
So first, we have a hidden class
pointer, which is an
internal notion of type, which
I'll explain in a second.
And then we have two pointers
to different kinds of
properties.
We have properties that have
string names and then
properties that have
int names.
But really, the only thing
that's important is you have a
type, and then you have
property storage.
So what's this hidden
class thing?
So hidden classes, again,
they're V8's
internal notion of type.
JavaScript itself isn't going to
enforce any kind of notion
of type on you.
But in order to make things
efficient, V8 itself needs to
have some sort of structure in
what it thinks you're doing.
So it introduces
a type system.
And that type system
groups objects
with the same structure.
So as you're adding properties
to objects, which you can do
in JavaScript, V8 will be
looking at the properties on
each object and mapping that
bundle of properties to a
hidden class, which defines an
object with exactly those
properties.
So, for instance, if I have this
constructor in JavaScript
where I have a point, and it
has an x and y, and the way
those values are added by first
adding x to the object
and then adding y, that's going
to generate a hidden
class that backs objects that
are created from this function
that has exactly the
properties x and y.
And that really seems
sort of obvious.
But then, the first time this
function is run, that hidden
class is going to be built
for the first time.
And then, all subsequent times
this function is run, those
new objects can share the
same hidden class.
So you only pay the price
for building it
the very first time.
After that, you can just
use the same object.
So we went through all this
trouble of building up a
notion of type.
So now, we have types that
correspond to specifically
what exact properties
are on an object.
We can use that notion of type
to make property access quick
using something called
inline caching.
So if you want to look up a
property on an object in
JavaScript, you're going to say,
I am looking for property
with name x on object y.
The first thing you do when
you're trying to look up a
property is check the hidden
class of the object.
If you've never tried to look up
that property on an object
of that type before, then what
you're going to have to do is
a fully generic search
for that property.
So again, we just have a bundle
of properties somewhere.
They all have string names.
You have a string of the
property you're looking for.
And you're going to have to look
through that list for the
property that has
a matching name.
That's a pretty slow
operation.
But once you found that
property once, you can
remember the offset to it.
You can remember where you found
that property and use it
later, which means that you can
use that to generate new
optimized code which specifies
how you look up that
particular property on that
particular object.
And the next time you want to
look up property with that
name on an object of
that type, you
can have direct access.
You know exactly where to go
in an object of that type.
And it's much, much,
much faster.
So that's really what the notion
of having hidden class
is getting us, is now we can
make property access really
fast through inline caching.
So this is a classic example
of a bad idea.
So I have another constructor.
It's creating a vector object.
It's adding an x and y.
But then, after I go through the
trouble of doing that, I
decide that I now wanted
property z on this object.
The problem with that is that
if you add a property z to
that object at some future
point, if you just dynamically
do that, you're going to change
the hidden class of the
object, which means that all
this nice caching you've done
and building up a notion of
where the properties are,
that's just blown away
because now you have
a new hidden class.
You have to pay to build the new
hidden class, and now you
have to deal with a
new hidden class.
So one of the best things you
can do to make your code
efficient is to create a
few well-defined types.
Don't do a lot of dynamic
property adding and removing
outside of constructors.
Pretty much set things up once,
have them look alike so
that they can share the same
hidden class, and don't mess
with the properties they have.
So now we know an object
has properties.
Those properties can be in
different storage states.
So the first state, the default,
is that they can be
stored directly in an
array on the object.
That's great.
That's fast. That's where
you want to be.
A second state they can be in
is being stored in array off
the objects.
Still great.
Still an array.
No problem.
The third case, which is the
one you really have to look
out for, is when they're
stored in a hash table.
So much like just the array case
in general where arrays
can have different types of
backing storage, properties
can have different types
of backing storage too.
So properties can either be in
normal mode where they're
stored as an array or a
dictionary mode where they're
stored as a hash table.
And if you have an object in
dictionary mode, it's going to
be much slower to
interact with.
So you don't want that.
So what triggers dictionary
mode, and how do you avoid it?
Well, one thing that triggers
it is too many properties.
So if you have so many
properties that they won't fit
into the internal storage for
properties, then you have to
have a hash table elsewhere.
And that number of too
many properties is
somewhere around 30.
It's quite generous, but you
might hit it in some cases.
The other things you can do to
confuse your object and kick
it into dictionary mode
are to change the
properties on that object.
You can change the attribute,
you can delete properties,
that kind of thing.
Those things are all going
to kick you straight to
dictionary mode.
Again, and now you're going to
make your object much slower
to interact with.
So that's object storage.
And we have a general idea of
what we want to do, which is
pretty much create repeating
common stable structures in
our code, not change them too
much so we can do all our nice
caching and stuff.
Now, we're going to talk about
the optimizing compiler which
is how you really make
JavaScript fast.
So the optimizing compiler is
the second of two compilers.
Remember, we had the
just-in-time compiler first,
which is doing its best to just
make the translation from
JavaScript to native code
as fast as it can.
And then, we have this other
compiler, the optimizing
compiler, which is actually
going to look at that code
that's generated and try to make
it really good fast code.
So because JavaScript doesn't
give you any language to tell
V8 what you're intending, the
only thing that the optimizing
compiler can do is sit back and
watch your system as it
warms up and try to infer
structures in your code.
It's going to watch
what you're doing.
It's going to watch for what
types are where and how the
data is flowing through it, and
then make inferences about
the kinds of optimizations
that it can do.
So this is a costly operation,
which is why we don't actually
just try to optimize
everything.
The system only tries to
optimize functions that have
been deemed to be worthwhile,
and that decision is made from
a profiler thread.
So when Crankshaft, which is
the name of V8's optimizing
compiler, spins up, spins up a
profiling thread to watch for
what functions are hot, when
it sees a function that it
thinks should be optimized, it
then looks at the type data
it's collected so far.
So it's like, ah, this function
seems to take ints
all the time.
And it seems to return this
kind of data, and
so on, and so forth.
And using that type data that
it's collected, it can do all
sorts of optimization.
It can inline code.
It can do loop invariant
code motion.
It can do all sorts of
optimizations and specialize
on those types.
Then, it can take the new
optimized fast path code it
generated, do on-stack
replacement to just swap it
out in place, hold on to the old
slow code, just in case it
needs it later, and continue on
executing without anybody
knowing the difference except
for that the code is much,
much faster now.
So the optimizing compiler is
really the heart of what will
make your game JavaScript
performant.
And you really need to be
working with this system to
try to play nice with it.
So what kind of structures are
optimized by Crankshaft?
Well, I'll tell you,
not everything.
Not everything is an eligible
construct in your JavaScript
for optimization.
When Crankshaft looks at a
function, it's like, ah, I
want to optimize that.
It starts trying to
optimize the code.
And then in the middle, it hits
something that it can't
actually do.
It finds something that
it can't optimize.
That's a condition
we call bailout.
Bailout means I tried
to optimize this.
I tried for you, but actually,
I couldn't
do it for some reason.
So I'm just going to not
try to optimize that.
And there are a number of things
that cause bailouts.
And they actually change
a good deal.
So one thing is that functions
are too long.
Functions that are really,
really long are not candidates
for optimization.
This is an interesting case
because some of these tools
that try to make your JavaScript
fast, like
post-processing tools, like
closure, some of those in some
cases do such aggressive
in-lining that they create
these giant functions.
And then, those giant functions
are no longer
candidates for optimization
by Crankshaft.
And so they actually make the
code a good deal slower.
I've seen this happen.
So when I see function too long,
you probably wouldn't
write it, a function
that long.
But something that's
post-processing your code might.
So you should keep
your eye on it.
And other than that, there are
just a number of specific
cases that can't be optimized.
If you want to see what's
being optimized and what
isn't, you can use these
two handy V8 flags.
You can use trace-bailout,
and trace-opt.
Tract-bailout will spit out
the function names of what
things are bailing
out and why.
Trace-opt will tell you what
functions are getting optimized.
So I have a bunch of specific
output from trace-bailout.
These actually came from a
recent trace that I ran.
And you can see, this
sort of makes sense.
They're very readable--
tryCatch not supported,
Forin not supported,
NonStringToString
not supported.
I debated a lot putting
them on the slide.
I wanted to put something up
here as representative.
But just know that these are the
types of things that will
change, like the V8 team is
trying to optimize this.
They're trying to handle
more cases.
So just keep checking in about
what in your code is bailing
out and what is working
well, and keep
watching with the flags.
So the thing is, all those
wonderful optimizations that
Crankshaft made for you when it
does successfully optimize
functions are speculative.
They are based on the
information that Crankshaft
has at the time they are made.
So again, the way Crankshaft
works, it
just watches the system.
It infers what patterns
are where.
It sees what the types kind of
are, and then, it tries to
specialize based on that.
So if your code always did
things a certain way, it
always passed this function
ints, and then suddenly, it's
like, nah, I want to pass this
function objects or strings or
whatever, suddenly, the
assumptions that were made to
optimize that code
are violated.
And that results in something
called the deopt, which is
where we have to take that slow
code that we kept around
just in case and swap it back
in for the fast code.
And deoptimizations
are really tragic.
They're sort of a double fail.
Because you paid to optimize the
code, which was expensive.
And you paid to swap it in.
And then you paid to swap
it back out again.
And now, you're running slow
code again on a function that
Crankshaft thought it
should optimize.
So you really don't want
deoptimizations.
The way you tell whether your
code is deopting is using
another handy flag in
V8-- trace-deopt.
And that, again, it'll
tell you the
names of the functions.
It'll output them to stdout,
the names of the functions
that are deopting and why.
So keep an eye on that as
you write your game.
So in general, what you should
be taking away from all this
is that JavaScript, it's
this wonderfully
elegant dynamic language.
So once you get used to it,
you can do all this stuff
which is very JavaScripty.
You can dynamically add
properties and take optional
arguments to functions and
use closures in this
very elegant way.
Whenever you see something
that's really dynamic and
really JavaScripty, you should
be a little bit suspicious,
because, just because you're
not writing native code,
doesn't mean that someone isn't
writing native code.
Remember that Crankshaft is over
here watching what you do
and trying to figure out what
you mean, trying to infer from
your program's behavior
what you mean.
So if you keep changing what
your program does, it can't
help you optimize.
So the more type stable and
predictable and C-like you can
make your code, the better
you're going to be.
So again, that's a
rule of thumb.
JavaScripty JavaScriptisms can
be fast. But if you want like
a hard-and-fast rule, the more
like C it is, those things are
likely to be faster.
So in terms of other rules, so
create a few well-defined
object types.
Don't add way too many
properties to objects.
Keep it reasonable.
Don't start changing the data
types your functions take.
Try to make things type
stable and C like.
Don't use functions that
are way too big.
And in general, just as you
develop, keep an eye on what's
going on in V8.
Profile occasionally with
trace-deopt, trace-GC,
trace-bailout, and see what's
going on and just keep an eye.
Now the last thing.
We'll talk about the
garbage collector.
So JavaScript, of course, is a
garbage-collected language.
And garbage collection hitches
are one of the very first
performance problems I hear
people complaining about.
When people write large-scale
JavaScript systems, one of the
first things they come back
with is like, wow, we're
getting this like sawtooth
performance curve.
What's up with that?
And that's the garbage
collector going.
So V8's garbage collector is
a precise, incremental,
generational garbage
collector.
Of all those adjectives, the
one you really need to care
about is generational, which
really just means there are
two areas of memory,
two or more.
There are actually more.
But two areas of memory for
all intents and purposes.
There is a small
area that's for
really short-lived objects.
And then, there's an area for
objects that are going to live
a long time.
And if you want to see what's
going on with the garbage
collector, you could run again
a handy dandy V8 flag--
trace-GC.
And that will spew a bunch of
information about what's going
on with the garbage collector
for your perusal.
So if you're trying to make
an application that is
garbage-collector friendly, one
of the things you should
be aware of is that promotion
is expensive.
So again, we have a
generational garbage collector.
So we have a young generation
and an older generation.
And the promotion of objects
from the young to the old
generation is expensive because
you're actually
copying an object out of one
area of memory into another
area of memory.
So one of the worst things you
can do is you can have an
object that lives just long
enough to get promoted, and
then you forget about it.
So you want, in general, either
objects that are going
to live a very short time or
objects that are going to live
a very long time.
Medium-lived objects, you're
kind of wasting some time
promoting them.
The other thing you need to be
aware of is that in a system
that is garbage collected, it's
very important that you
release your references
to things.
Pretty obvious, except for that
in JavaScript, you can
have these large systems that
are sort of hard to tell
what's going.
Also, there are some tricky
things in JavaScript that can
hold on to references for you.
So for instance, execution
contexts and closures can both
hold onto references
for objects and not
let them get collected.
So you need to be a little
careful with your JavaScript.
Keep track of where all
your memory is.
And then, the number one thing
you can do to make a
garbage-collector friendly
application is to
not generate garbage.
And that will help you
avoid GC stalls.
So the difficulty with that is
that most things are objects
in JavaScript.
Temp variables, closures, all of
this other kind of stuff is
JavaScript.
Very few things aren't.
Small ints, for instance,
are one thing that is
an immediate value.
So that's another really good
reason to use small ints.
Other than that, good rules of
thumb are to use scratch pads,
sort of reuse variables between
functions, and to
update things in place
where you can.
So, for instance, this is an
example of a classic bad idea.
So it's just a simple
vector add function.
One of the first things
you're going to
need is a math library.
You might think that this was a
good way to write it, except
for that this actually allocates
a brand new vector
object every time you try to
do a vector add, which is
going to be often.
So that's going to be really,
really garbage-collector
unfriendly.
This is a much better
way to write it.
I actually much prefer
the first syntax.
But this is a much better way to
write it in the context of
a garbage collector where
you actually add
to the first vector.
You just update the first
vector in place.
You don't allocate
a new object.
So this is going to
work a lot better.
Subtle point here is that if
you're working with doubles
again, you might be boxing and
allocating new heap numbers.
So this might create
some garbage
collector pressure anyway.
But it's still going
to be much better.
So now you know how to write a
high-performance JavaScript
application.
Or hopefully, you have some
intuition as to what might be
fast, what might be slow, and
how to check whether things
are going well or not
in your JavaScript.
That's awesome.
Now, we have to take that
application and put it Chrome
in the context of Chrome
where all this other
stuff is going on.
So let's talk about that.
So first of all, when you're
in Chrome or when you're in
any browser, it's just very
different than being on a PC
or a console.
There's a lot of stuff
you don't know.
You don't know what
browser you're in.
And different browsers, they
have different performance
profiles for different
operations.
And also, they support
different HTML5 API.
So every single thing you do,
you need to check whether it's
supported here.
You don't know anything about
the local hardware.
And this is a really hard one
for people to get their head
around how important this is.
Most game developers who are
coming from the console PC
space have never had to deal
with a range of hardware so
broad as you have
to for the web.
Everything from a five-year-old
phone to the
latest and greatest desktop
system of today, that's the
range of things that
can run HTML5.
And so you can get these huge
performance differences, which
means that it's very important
that you do a lot of checking
in your code about what the
local system can handle.
Another thing you have
to know is that your
game lives in a tab.
What does that mean to you?
It means that that tab can
actually close at any time.
Now, this is always true.
If you're writing a console
game, the user can walk up and
hit the power button
on the console.
That's always an issue, except
for that the way people
interact with tabs in a browser
is far more ephemeral.
It's very normal for somebody
to be playing a web game and
then be like, oh, I want to
check email and just close
that tab down.
And this is important for you
to know, because if you're
writing files to local cache or
something like that, you're
going to have to be very careful
that you're ready to
be shut down at any time.
There might be other
applications running in your
same thread.
Here, I'm talking about
Chrome specifically.
So you might not have the whole
thread to work with.
And there's this other
compositing and rendering
cycle that's going around your
game that's making the whole
web page itself.
And so you need to fit
into that as well.
So let's talk about this
local hardware thing.
So you know nothing about
the local environment.
And I know I just said
this, but I really
can't stress it enough.
Because of privacy concerns,
there's nothing in JavaScript
that allows you to ask detailed
questions about a
user's local machine.
So there's no way that
you can ask what kind
of hardware is this?
What can it support?
So you're just in charge
of being able to
scale on your own.
And in the PC world,
this is not a
problem because PC games--
console games don't have this
problem to begin with.
PC games specifically say
on them what the system
requirements are.
And everybody's used to that.
Everybody's happy with that.
On the web, people have this
expectation that everything be
lowest common denominator,
which is a
blessing and a curse.
I love that you get broad
distribution.
However, it makes it really
hard if you're trying to
target the high end.
And so what you can do that
this is just be very, very
clear with your users about
how your game will run on
their machine.
The last thing you want is to
have your users buy your game
from some web app store, the
Chrome Web Store, for
instance, and try to play it,
and then find that it doesn't
run, or it runs at 5 FPS or
whatever, because they're
running on very old hardware.
And then, they give you
a one-star review.
They're like, this game sucks.
I can't run it.
So you really, really need to
be communicating proactively
with your users about
what they can
expect from your game.
I can't stress that enough.
It's like really important
for end-user experience.
Also, if you can, you want
graceful degradation where
it's not just a binary thing.
You want to be able to make your
games gracefully scaled
down to fit on lower-end
hardware.
So one thing you can do
to that end is micro
benchmarking.
And so this is where
you, yourself--
again, it's all home brew.
Nothing in the JavaScript
standards helps you.
But you, yourself, write little
benchmarks that stress
what your game is going
to stress and
collects data about that.
So maybe, during your loading
screen, you run a bunch of
tests, get a feeling about what
the local system is, and
then suggest settings or send
that data back to your service
for analysis.
Or while the game is running,
you see what the FPS is and
adjust accordingly or take
data accordingly.
But you really need to
be proactive about
collecting this data.
And that's pretty much it for
dealing with the hardware
variation you're going to
find in HTML5 games.
Collect data, communicate, and
make sure, above all, that you
set your users' expectations
appropriately.
So up until now, I've been
talking about HTML5
specifications.
I've been talking about how to
make JavaScript fast. Those
things all live within V8.
So here, we're talking about
things that live in V8.
Let's talk about what
goes around that.
So V8 lives in WebKit alongside
CSS and HTML.
So the same way V8 executes
JavaScript, there's another
machine for HTML and another
system for CSS.
All of those things
live side by side.
When they want to render things,
any one of those
things can send commands
on this RPC
buffer to the GPU process.
All rendering in Chrome is done
in a separate process
entirely, not just a separate
thread, a separate process.
And it's done on a separate
process for security reasons.
And so this structure is very
important to understand
because you're sharing this
RPC buffer with everything
else that's trying to
render anything.
Then from the GPU process, it'll
actually communicate
with the drivers and the
hardware itself to do the
actual rendering.
But there are a couple of
additional pieces of
complexity here.
One is that on Windows where
you don't have good OpenGL
drivers, there's this layer
called ANGLE, Almost Native
Graphics Layer Engine.
And that will do a translation
from OpenGL to DirectX.
And then, there's this other
translation layer called
SwiftShader.
So on machines that don't have
good drivers or drivers that
are good enough for WebGL,
SwiftShader will actually do
software rasterization.
So there's all this complexity
from your game on down into
the actual rendering.
So let's talk about that.
So first, let's talk about
the RPC buffer part.
So if you remember way back
when I was talking about
WebGL, I mentioned that
certain commands have
unexpectedly slow performance.
And those are anything that
starts with "read," anything
that starts with "get," these
things that require round
trips to the GPU.
And now that you understand that
there's an RPC buffer in
there and rendering is done on a
separate process, I'm hoping
that you'll have some intuition
for why that is and
what sorts of command
might be slow.
So besides that, the other thing
you have to know about
that buffer is that
it's shared, and
it's limited in size.
So there's a specific size
limit on that buffer.
And all the resources that you
upload to the GPU are going to
eat up that size.
And it's total size of
resources, not total of number
of resources.
But all your textures, all
your buffers, all your
commands, they're all
going to go into the
budget for that buffer.
And if you go over that buffer
size, then you're going to
trigger something called a sink
flush, which is slow.
And it's going to amount
to a stall.
So that means that you're trying
to send another command
on that buffer.
But the buffer is
already full.
And so the buffer is like,
ah, no room for that.
So I have to stop and actually
process through the whole
thing, have to flush everything
out before I can
process this new command.
And what that's going to look
like to you is that suddenly,
one of the commands you're
sending to OpenGL is going to
look like it takes a really
long time for no reason in
your profiling view.
You're like, wow, that command
was always perfectly fine, and
now, it's taking 40
milliseconds.
And that's because you spilled
the buffer, and you triggered
a sink flush.
So really, the only thing you
can do here is try to amortize
the cost of uploading
across frames.
So just try to limit what
you do per frame.
If you see these big stalls, you
can have an intuition that
you're probably or might be
spilling that buffer and act
accordingly.
One note here is that when I
talked about this with the
Chrome GPU team, they said yes,
this is true for now.
This is good information.
But this is something
that's subject to
change in the future.
So keep checking back in
with this assumption.
Hopefully, this will get better,
that this problem of
causing sink flushes won't be
a problem in the future.
But for now, this
is good advice.
So now, let's talk about the
close to the hardware type
part of the system.
So what do you need to
know about drivers?
Really just that they're
there, and that not all
drivers are secure.
Not all drivers are stable
for use with WebGL.
And that means in order to
keep people's browsing
experiences secure and stable,
that many or some drivers are
blacklisted.
So sometimes, people running
on a computer that is
perfectly a-- computer and
browser perfectly capable of
playing your game will not be
able to use WebGL because
their drivers are blacklisted.
And unfortunately, the only way
to test whether the local
machine is capable of running
WebGL is by actually trying to
create a context and
seeing if it fails.
So the first thing you do when
you're making a WebGL
application is make
a WebGL context.
And you really just have to try
it, see if it works, and
then handle accordingly.
There's no more elegant
way than that.
The other thing I mentioned is
this Almost Native Graphics
Layer Engine, which in response
to the fact that, in
general, DirectX rendering works
better on Windows than
OpenGL rendering, or rather,
OpenGL drivers for Windows
tend to be somewhat buggy or
unstable, there's this layer
called ANGLE, which will
translate your OpenGL calls
into DirectX before rendering
on Windows only.
Hopefully, you never need
to know about this.
It's just sort of trivia.
But it's good for you to know
that it's there just in case.
And then, finally, we
have SwiftShader.
Again, this is software
rasterization.
So if you have a system that's
capable of running your game,
but for some reason, their
drivers don't work, then you
might get SwiftShader,
SwiftShader software
rasterization.
Now, this is just another case
where you're going to have to
be really proactive about
judging the performance of the
local machine, because, of
course, software rasterization
is going to be nowhere
near as performant as
hardware-accelerated OpenGL.
So you need to be really careful
that you're catching
these cases, and testing the
performance, and degrading
appropriately, or informing
the user appropriately.
Again, you never had any
guarantees about software
rasterization or not.
It could always have been a
10-year-old graphics card.
Now, you have software
rasterization in the mix.
That just hammers home that
point a little bit harder.
So let's talk about your
rendering loop for your game.
So old-style JavaScript, the
way you would do periodic
function calls are with these
two methods, setInterval and
setTimeout.
But the problem with those is
that there's no way to tell
the browser what you're doing.
And again, much like we were
seeing with the V8 case when
we were talking about performant
JavaScript,
performant rendering in general,
being performant in
general, is about being able
to inform the system what
you're doing in specific
terms so that it can
optimize around you.
SetInterval and setTimeout are
not specific about what
they're doing.
They could be doing anything.
We don't know that this
is an animation.
So the browser can't do
anything to help you.
And that's why they're
bad ideas.
Instead, there's this nice API
in the HTML5 family of APIs
called RequestAnimationFrame.
And this is a way to do periodic
rendering in a way
that tells the browser exactly
what you mean.
So RequestAnimationFrame will
try to call at 60 hertz, and
it'll adapts down if you can't
actually call at 60 hertz.
It'll never call faster
than that.
But it'll call slower
if it needs to.
So because the
RequestAnimationFrame callback
is always going to be scaling
its performance to how long
your frames are taking, if you
can't run at 60 hertz, then
your frame rate's going to go
a little jaggy, because it's
going to be based on how long
one of the recent frames took.
And so if you don't want your
frame rate to wander, you need
to clamp it to either
60 or 30.
If you're trying to clamp your
frame rate to 30, what you do
is just the simplest
thing possible.
You're just going to manually
skip frames by making a
counter that counts up, and you
render on even frames and
not on odd frames,
or whatever.
So that's what you want to do
if having a jaggy frame rate
bothers you.
And the other thing that
RequestAnimationFrame can do
for you, because it knows that
you are animating, it can feed
Chrome's rendering pipeline
with your data at
a consistent rate.
And it can adapt the work you do
on the GPU and CPU to make
sure that you're not just
throwing a bunch of commands
over the wall that you could
never possibly render on the
GPU, that you're not totally
swamping everything.
That's what
RequestAnimationFrame gives you.
So this is a typical
game loop.
You have update, render, swap,
update, render, swap.
That's pretty normal, you know,
while true, do this.
That's a game.
This is the way it
fits into Chrome.
So you have
RequestAnimationFrame, which
is your JavaScript code.
You have composite, which Chrome
takes care of that.
That's where everything is
smooshed together and rendered
on the screen, and then, you
have a swap as well.
So that loop is going on if you
have the main loop of your
game in there.
If you didn't have that, the
browser would just go back to
idle and sit idly.
User input can also cause a
screen dirty, which causes a
composite, which causes a swap,
which then either goes
back to idle or goes
back into your
RequestAnimationFrame loop.
So now, let's talk about
the life of a frame.
So the way frames work in
Chrome is that we have
RequestAnimationFrame calls.
So first thing that's done is
that your JavaScript in your
RequestAnimationFrame
call is executed.
And during that JavaScript,
it'll kick off a bunch of
calls that result in commands
on the GPU.
So you're going to kick off
commands down that RPC buffer
that are going to go on to this
other rendering process.
When all your JavaScript is
completed, and all your GPU
work is completed, you have all
the information you need,
so you can composite the whole
frame together, and
you could do a swap.
So that's the general cycle.
You do your JavaScript
callback, which kicks
off your GPU work.
When all that's done,
you can composite.
And then you just wait out
the rest of the frame.
If your frame is under 16
milliseconds, it'll just wait
until the next call of
RequestAnimationFrame.
So yes, it just keeps
on like that.
So in that diagram I showed
you before about how all
things fit together, one thing
I left out is user input.
So I want to talk a little
bit about user input now.
One really important thing you
need to know is that while
your main JavaScript thread
is busy, input is queued.
And that can introduce
a lot of input
latency into your code.
So let me talk about how
that actually works.
So here we have a diagram
similar to before, so it's
showing a series of frames.
First, you do your
JavaScript work.
Then you do your GPU work.
And you just keep doing that.
If during my JavaScript work
I get a bunch of mouse move
events, I'm not going to
hear them right away.
I can't hear them while the
main thread is busy.
And they came in when the
Once the JavaScript execution
is done, you're eligible to
hear a mouse event.
So here, in this case,
I'm going to
hear this most freshest--
most recent, freshest
mouse click.
Then during the next frame,
now I've got a m event.
Now I'm eligible during the
next frame to process that
mouse event.
And then at the very end
of the next frame when
everything's rendered, the
result of that mouse input can
get rendered.
And so you can see, especially
with this queuing delay, where
if events come in while the main
thread is busy, they just
get queued up, and you can't
hear them until later, you can
have a lot of input latency.
The rule of thumb is that your
input latency is going to be
approximately twice
your frame length.
So if these are 16-millisecond
frames, then the maximum input
latency you can get if you're
unlucky is 32 milliseconds,
which is a hell of
a lot of latency.
But that's sort of the system
that you live in.
So you just have to be ready
to deal with that.
The other thing you can do to
help yourself is to move work
off the main thread.
So moving work to
the GPU is good.
Moving work to web
workers is good.
Anything that helps you free up
the main thread to be able
to receive user input
is good for you.
So one more thing to talk about
user input is that one
of the really important things
that RequestAnimationFrame
does is it allows Chrome
to schedule your work
accordingly.
So again, we see the same
simplified version of the
diagram we've been looking at
where you have your work, and
then Chrome's work,
and then wait.
Your work, and then Chrome's
work, and then wait, and so
on, and so forth.
This all makes perfect sense,
nice repeating pattern.
But when you have outside
events, DOM events or timers,
or things going off that cause
things at unexpected
intervals, Chrome no longer has
the ability to schedule
those things.
They just happened
in on events.
So in this case, on the slide,
I got this on-click event.
It required some work.
That processing all would have
fit in this frame nicely.
But because Chrome didn't know
about that work, it couldn't
schedule, it which means that
this frame is actually going
to be delivered late.
It's going to wait for that
on-click event to complete.
It's going to deliver
the frame late.
And then, the next frame, frame
N+1, is actually going
to have a shorter time
in which to execute.
So what this means to you is
essentially never do any work
outside of
RequestAnimationFrame.
If you want like a DOM-based hub
over your WebGL game, what
you really want to be doing is
buffering up all user input
and then handling those
user inputs in the
RequestAnimationFrame
callback.
You don't want to just handle
them whenever they come in.
Because you have to think about
how Chrome is actually
scheduling the work.
You have to give Chrome a chance
to pack that work in
nicely, which means that you
have to actually do any
processing you want
to do inside the
RequestAnimationFrame
callback.
So just in summary of what we've
learned about living
inside Chrome, first
of all, throttle
your upload per frame.
Watch out for big performance
stalls.
Those are probably
sink flushes.
And they mean that you're
uploading too much data at
once essentially.
Your game lives inside Chrome,
so you have to respect
Chrome's natural rendering cycle
and have to be prepared
to give 2 to 4 milliseconds per
frame to Chrome for all
the compositing and swapping
and finalizing that Chrome
needs to do.
So you don't actually have
16 milliseconds.
You actually have 12.
Hopefully, it will come in under
4, but you have to be
prepared to give
that much away.
Never handle outside
events directly.
Never handle user events
directly in events.
Make sure you queue all the
work you need to do up and
handle it in RAF.
All the work you do should
be inside your
RequestAnimationFrame callback
if you want Chrome to be able
to schedule it nicely.
And then, if you're concerned
about input latency, if that's
a big deal for you, then the
best thing you can do there is
move work off your
main thread.
Move it to the GPU, move it
to Web Workers, whatever.
Just know that the input is
blocked or queued while the
main thread is busy.
And that's just going to imply
some input latency for you.
So in general, all this amounts
to be aware of what
Chrome is doing and how you
fit inside it and try
to work with that.
So we've talked about how to
write fast JavaScript.
We've talked about how to make
that JavaScript work well
inside of Chrome.
And now, just in the short time
I have left, I'm going to
talk about the developer tools
you need to check how well
you're doing.
So first of all, just be aware
that Chrome's got all these
handy dandy flags.
So you can type about and then
a number of things different
into Chrome to get
some cool stats.
So there's about:flags, which
has a lot of graphics options,
including an FPS counter,
which I essentially just
perpetually leave on.
There's about:memory, which
shows you exactly what's going
on with memory in Chrome.
It's a very in-depth
detailed view.
There's about:gpu, which is
useful for figuring out what
Chrome thinks your
GPU stats are.
Or if you're taking bug reports
from external people,
it's really nice to get
them to dump that data
and give it to you.
So these are all tools you
should be aware of.
Then we have the Chrome
developer tools.
So the Chrome developer tools
are really, really useful.
They were designed. or
had been used most
often on web pages.
They're really, really
great for web pages.
They're also good for games,
but they've been optimized
around that case.
So for instance, the CPU
profiler only take samples
every 1 or 2 milliseconds.
So it's a lot less resolution
than you would want.
But they're really good
for some things.
So how you get to the developer
tools, there's a
wrench icon up in the upper
right hand of Chrome.
Then you go to the Tools menu,
go to Developer Tools.
And the things you should be
aware of there are the
timeline view, which completely
rocks for trying to
see how your resource
loads are going.
That's the thing that I find it
most useful for, is seeing
where resource requests were
made and how long they took.
There's the CPU profiler,
standard profiler.
Again, resolution a little
low, but it still can be
really useful.
And then there's the heap
profiler, which is a super
useful in-depth look
at exactly where
all your memory is.
So those are the tools that are
most important, I think,
of the Chrome developer tools
for game developers.
And then, there's
about:tracing.
So about:tracing is the heaviest
weight tool you
should be aware of in Chrome if
you're actually trying to
debug a game.
So this view that's on the
slide, pretty confusing the
first time you look at it.
Every one of these colored
lines, colored vertical lines,
represents a function call
that's instrumented.
And so this actually gives you a
list of all the instrumented
function calls on every Chrome
process, so for every open
tab, as well as calls
for the GPU.
So this is the tool you're going
to look at if you're
going to want to see how
your CPU work and
your GPU work relate.
This is what's going
to be useful.
If you zoom way in on that view
I just showed you, you
can see that each one of those
colored boxes, actually, you
can see a function name in it.
And that function name
data is really raw.
Again, it's right out
of the source code.
So if you don't know what draw
layers means in this
particular context, then
that's too bad.
But you can kind of look at the
function names and make
educated guesses about
what they mean.
And then the really useful thing
you can do with this is
that from JavaScript, you
can add console.time and
console.timeEnd tags with
your own string tag.
And that will create a colored
box in this view, just like
all the other function calls
that will manually instrument
a function call for you.
And you can see exactly where
your function call happened
within your frame.
So this is a tool you
definitely, definitely want to
be aware of.
And then finally, I know I
mentioned this in the section
about JavaScript, but you really
should be checking your
code with V8 flags.
Unfortunately, this information
about what
JavaScript is fast and
slow isn't surfaced
really well to the user.
It's all sort of at
the command line.
But it's very, very important
information.
And so I also put up
here exactly how to
run this for a Mac.
It's not really friendly being
on a slide, but I wanted
people to have these slides
after the fact as reference to
be able to refer to it.
So that's actually a call you
can cut and paste into your
Mac to make this happen.
And then finally, there's
WebGL Inspector.
So WebGL Inspector is an
open-source Chrome extension
which patterns itself after
PIX or one of these other
heavyweight graphics debugging
tools that people in the games
industry especially are
really fond of.
So if you want to step through
your draw calls or see exactly
how your textures are bound
something like that, WebGL
Inspector is going to be very,
very useful to you.
So you should definitely
check that out.
And then finally, one more note
before I'm out of time.
I just want to stress
that we really,
really, really want feedback.
It's not at all knowing or
unwelcome to file bugs.
It's really welcome.
I really, really look forward to
working with teams that are
verbose about what they want.
And they file bugs in Chrome.
And they sort of squawk a lot
about what's working and
what's not working.
So please, please, please,
when you find things that
don't work in Chrome, or things
you'd like to work
better, or features
you want, please
log things into crbug.com.
That's the Chrome
bug database.
Or if there are features you
want in WebGL or in any of the
HTML5 specifications, please go
to those mailing lists and
talk about what you need and
what your experience is.
The community is not so large
that you can't make a
difference.
Really, the decisions are made
by the people who show up.
And you are really capable
of influencing what
actually gets done.
So please, please, please
email those
mailing lists, file bugs.
Everybody really wants
to hear from you.
All right.
And that's it.
Thank you very much.